alors voici la fameuse marinade la chine
controversé bonjour
sans compter le vieux les enfants
bonjour vous si la bataille de votre été
et des prochains mois vous voulez pas
que ça ferme
absolument depuis le 9 juillet depuis
l'annnonce 18 juillet dernier ont fait
des représentations des diverses
manières le pourrais absolument
s'assurer que ça reste ouvert
absolument on va aller faire un tour
[Musique]
voulait pas perdre l'accès ici à la
chine votre mari ne vous en faites vous
comprenez pas les motivations de la
ville
non parce que ici la marina existe
depuis près de 100 ans qui a déjà une
cohabitation qui fait avec les autres
clubs le club d'aviron le club de voile
le caillou le canoë kayak puis les
berges sont accessibles à plus de 90%
ici à la chine pour les citoyens donc
non comprend pas les motivations est ce
que votre mairesse avait plus du saut
avait dit ça dans ses engagements
électoraux
non justement c'est ça qui nous dérange
parce que c'était pas annoncé dans son
programme électoral
on a appris ça par surprise sans préavis
en pleine pandémie le 8 juillet dernier
tout le monde sait ont été atterrés par
ça mais le problème c'est que fillon
s'était on avait su à l'avancé qu'on
avait fait des consultations publiques
qu'on s'était assis tout le monde
ensemble kayak l'aviron la voile les
citoyens on aurait pu trouver les
meilleures solutions
mais là on est mise sur le fait accompli
en moins de deux mois on doit s'en aller
on est chassé et puis on n'est pas nulle
part où aller
la ville prétend que c'est trop vieux ça
coûterait une fortune remettre à niveau
les installations derrière ben oui mais
nous on ne comprend pas non plus à 16.5
millions qu'ils avancent on n'a
malheureusement pas vu le détail précis
de tout ça et on a fait des contre
expertises avec des ingénieurs civils et
des entrepreneurs en construction on
arrive à 5.3 millions dont 3 points et
clu inclut la rénovation des berges donc
et on a proposé aussi de payer davantage
à nos pratiques fait s'assurer que ce ne
soit pas un fardeau pour les
contribuables
ouais parce que c'est loïc 10 a fait
faillite c'est pas rentable
ouais vous vous dites on est prêt à
payer plus on est prêt à payer plus de
base on est rentable selon les
informations fournies par la ville et
les anciennes administrations ont fait
soit kifkif ou 100 mille dollars de
surplus d'exploitation par année
l'histoire d'être des privilégiés
nous on a un bateau de vin pas ok on est
pas d une famille riche puis pour la
majorité d'entre nous ce n'est pas le
cas ceci coûte moins cher que la
majorité des chalets québec québécois en
mai en profite ici à montréal des lieux
au lieu de devoir s'exiler en banlieue
en conclusion d'un côté vous vous
demandez au moins j'imagine qu'il ya un
autre était la coke que la discussion se
poursuit oui absolument cesser la façon
démocratique qu'on aurait souhaité que
ça se passe qu'on soit avisé al avance
et qu'il nous donne le temps de bien
faire les choses mais je pense que
plusieurs citoyens qui sont même pas au
courant que la wacc les amériques 9 et
en assume on leur demande de revenir sur
leur position de s'asseoir autour d'une
table tenir des consultations publiques
puis après on peut prendre des décisions
plus éclairées
donc j'ai gelé pour l'instant on va voir
on va aller voir la mairesse merci
beaucoup aux plaisirs
madame la mairesse bon jour en jour
pourquoi vous voulez chasser les bateaux
de votre marina qui est la plus grande
marina du québec on on veut faire un
projet différent le terrain nous
appartient elle nous appartient depuis
longtemps c'est un énorme fardeau fiscal
pour très très peu de gens comparé à la
population de montréal pourquoi ne pas
faire le débat démocratique et peut-être
que vous avez tout à fait raison dans
votre projet mais donner du temps à la
consultation de ces gens là pourquoi
pourquoi ça urge la preuve que ça soit 6
là parce que c'est en fin de vie parce
que là la peau la pompe à essence est en
fait une vie on doit à la renouveler
parce que la fosse septique est enfin un
ami ça marche pas parce qu'on a déjà 60
et 2 - parce qu'il faut refaire toutes
les coulisses béton parce qu'il faut
refaire toute l'électricité parce qu'il
faut refaire toutes les berges d'une
campagne électorale dans un an
oui pourquoi pas remercions pour la
campagne électorale et en faire un enjeu
électoral mais parce que l'année
prochaine la marina ne peut pas exister
il ya trop à faire en ce moment il ya
des coûts faramineux pour la ville de
montréal faramineux parce qu'un autre
était donnez leur un an pour que tout le
monde réfléchisse parce que des gens de
l'extérieur
oui des gens qui est des urbanistes y
réfléchisse à saurez vous ont reproché
de dire il y en eu précipitation on
quand on veut tuer son chien on dit
qu'il a la rage la boue dit c'est comme
si tout était en train de démolir
ça fait des années que c'est comme ça et
on regarde la situation en pleine face
si on la regarde et il ya des travaux
qui doivent être faits et on va le faire
vous savez pour la première fois avec
les citoyens et on va le faire avec les
plaisanciers
parce qu'il est toujours question de
garder une marine locale parce qu'on
veut une cohabitation
alors il est question de garder une
marina locales pour couvrir cette marina
c'est à eux de définir
l'important c'est que cette marina
soient autofinancés au toucher
ray et qu'elle ne soit pas un fardeau
pour la ville qu'on évoque les autres
fruits qui vient nous faire une
proposition à ses tunes marino sur votre
branche marine ah non je dis c'est une
marina local qu'on fait ça toujours été
dans les plans est ce qu'il pourrait
avoir à terme autant de places de
bateaux pourrait jamais avoir 405 en
watts au cse qui aura moins de bateaux
mais disons entre 60 et 100 quelque
chose on verra pas ce que vous voyez que
ça brasse et quand lui et lui il faut
être à l'écouté des gens voyez que ça
brasse aucun doute dans votre esprit 0
n'ya pas aucun de ces en ce moment c'est
une décision pragmatique mais il ya une
consultation publique qui s'en vient à
laquelle les plaisanciers sont invités
mais c'est certain que le statu quo
étant donné la situation il ne peut pas
il ne peut pas exister
merci madame amberg immersive